dr jack bright is one of the
foundation's most enigmatic and chaotic
figures infamous for being the subject
of a humorous joke file passed between
personnel titled the things dr bright is
not allowed to do at the foundation
which describes well
exactly that by reading the list you'd
get an idea that this dr bright fellow
is a pretty fun and goofy guy certainly
popular enough to get an entire list
that he has himself as the sole
punchline but while that much is true
it's not the whole story sure he's a
strange man with an even stranger sense
of humor but a lot of that apparent
weirdness comes from jack wright's
experiences throughout his life or lives
we should say we'll explain needless to
say he has quite the story to tell for
starters dr jack bright is immortal not
in the sense that he cannot die but that
his soul itself is permanently affixed
to an amulet which has been given the
designation scp-963-1
originally the amulet was in possession
of the foundation as a minor anomalous
object that was incapable of being
damaged while dr bright was transporting
the amulet the deadly warrior
scp-076-2 nicknamed abel broke free from
its resting coffin and went on a
murderous rampage throughout the
facility dr bright who was holding
scp-963-1 was one of the first killed in
action days later after the chaos had
subsided a foundation rescue team
recovered bright's body from the
wreckage with
scp-963-1 along with it when the d-class
operative who stumbled upon the amulet
put it on he gained the memories
personality and consciousness of jack
bright the mind of the d-class was wiped
entirely and only bright remained when
the amulet was removed the d-class went
into a vegetative state ceasing all
brain activity thanks to
scp-963-1 dr bright is immortal his
consciousness is stored in the amulet
itself and transfers to whoever puts it
on after a 30-day period of wearing the
amulet the new body's brain will become
a duplicate of the late dr brights even
when the amulet is removed from their
person this could effectively allow a
whole number of dr brights to run wildly
around the foundation if left unchecked
thankfully the foundation has many
safety measures in place to prevent
exactly that from happening such as
limiting the current bright host body to
one person and keeping an eye on which
body bright is presently occupying
unfortunately this hasn't always worked
as you'll see in today's scp briefing
scp-4498 the plurality of jack bright
being immortal has a few downsides for
one bride feels tied to the amulet
unable to be released he's occupied
countless bodies and longs for a way out
deep down he's aware that he may never
truly die doomed to a fate of eternal
body switching until the universe burns
out maybe that's where bright's
goofiness comes from he plays the act of
a clown to hide the pain and tragedy of
his life regardless of how bright may
act no one can deny that his story isn't
tragic but this particular event was a
little less than tragic in fact it was a
bright overload the exact kind of
scenario the foundation wanted to
prevent through their containment
procedures of scp-963
and the tracking of which body bright
was currently occupying in fact that's
what scp-4498
is it's the designation given to a group
of over 325 men women animals and
anomalous entities who were previously
assigned to foundation facility site 53
who now assume the consciousness of dr
jack bright but how did this happen more
importantly how does the foundation keep
such a wild array of characters
contained well since
scp-4498 makes up the entire personnel
of a former site the foundation was able
to establish a quarantined exclusion
zone where site 53 used to be
interaction with the bright instances
was limited to only necessary
communications and separation of an
scp-4498 instance from the quarantined
exclusion zone was not permitted in case
any of the instances acted out of line
as dr bright tends to do from time to
time an applied task force named bright
99 oh no you don't was created to subdue
any rowdy brights and keep them where
they belong through the use of
non-lethal means until the foundation is
able to find a way to neutralize the
effects of scp-4498
the former personnel of site-53 are
stuck in containment harboring the
consciousness of jack bright but again
how did this even happen on may 9th 2018
an unexpected interaction between a now
neutralized anomaly and
scp-963-1 at site-53 resulted in the
creation of this quirky anomaly
bright had been assigned to the facility
because of his expertise regarding a
certain anomaly they were studying a
small porcelain cat statue that appeared
to negate or depress the effects of
nearby anomalies when its tail was
turned clockwise but on that day when dr
bright arrived at work he mishandled the
object instead of turning the tail
clockwise he turned it counterclockwise
by accident this resulted in the tail
breaking off of the statue and
triggering a new never-before-seen
anomalous effect that amplified and
engulfed the entire site once it
interacted with scp-963-1
the amulet hanging from bright's neck
upon breaking the tail the lights at
site-53 flickered and all personnel
collapsed to the floor and the security
cameras lost power when the security
cameras rebooted all personnel were
standing straight up there was immediate
confusion especially among the research
team who was observing bright's
inspection of the anomaly they weren't
sure what happened one researcher
suggested that they had all swapped
bodies another was confused as to why he
was in his current body on the count of
three the researchers decided to shout
out their names just to see who ended up
in whose body on three they all yelled
the same name jack bright the
implications of what happened were just
beginning to sink in dr bright then
called his longtime friend dr sophia
light site director of the famous site
17. the phone call between light and
bright was panicked as jack described
the emergency to his friend and
attempted to find a solution okay we
were working on that dumb little cat
thing that was going to use in the
anchor trials right maybe two hours ago
i i don't know i was looking at it and
then i went to turn the tail dr light
immediately knew what bright was talking
about clockwise right
yes clockwise uh when i turned it uh
clockwise it broke in my hand just like
that poof dr light could sense that
something had gone majorly wrong just
from the way bright emphasized the word
poof for a few moments bright danced
around the implication that he was
responsible for breaking the cat hoping
instead to use a less incriminating
euphemism light finally got him to spit
it out they're all me every single one
of them sophia i know i'm me obviously
i'm wearing the amulet but dr bright was
cut off seconds later he returned to the
phone clearly relieved that he wasn't
seen by any of the bright clones that
were now patrolling site 53. they're out
here storming around throwing stuff
writing naughty words on the whiteboards
they're
mad
every single one of them the site isn't
in lockdown i'm sitting here in the
bathroom trying to stay out of sight and
i need an evac sofia dr light was
unamused and asked why these wacky
events always seemed to happen while she
was busy bright begged and pleaded
asking her to send a task force or to
check and see what dr mann could do
light shot down bright's request saying
that man was at a conference off-site
when bright asked where light informed
him that it was at site 53 and that he
had just gotten there a few minutes ago
bright paused shuttered and struggled to
stay calm as he informed light that he
was at site 53 too this was the site
where the
scp-4498 anomaly had taken effect the
security cameras showed utter chaos
across site 53 the team dr mann brought
alongside him to the conference was
composed of the foundation's all-stars
famous names like dr gears agent troy
lament dr kane pathos crow and even the
infamous dr clef these foundation
superstars were on the run being pursued
by a mob of angry jack bright
scp-4498 instances who wielded broken
furniture tires and kitchen utensils in
their pursuit of the conference goers
site 53 was put on lockdown and after
several hours of radio silence mobile
task force reyes 7 gate guns arrived to
infiltrate the site and de-escalate the
situation when the task force operatives
arrived they immediately began to search
for dr bright unsurprisingly when they
called out to him several voices
responded when the task force lead
introduced himself and informed the
instances that they were sent to extract
dr bright an scp-4498
instance that took over the body of
site-53 personnel dr herman donaldson
brandished a rifle and informed the
operatives that they were all jack
bright he told the task force to leave
and that the situation was under control
as he was saying this an explosion was
heard behind him which the instance
seemed completely unfazed by when the
lead reiterated that they were just
there to extract dr mann his team and
the real jack bright the instances got
upset at the implication that they were
anything less than the genuine article
it was certain
scp-4498 had taken over site 53 and they
were the ones calling the shots the
foundation's quiet and kind dr kiru then
stood up now affected by
scp-4498 and wearing a flashy jacket and
hat she introduced herself as the pirate
queen jack bright and spoke in a heavy
pirate accent when the task force
attempted to breach the site further dr
kiru and her devoted crewmates fired
upon them though since they were all
jack brights they were actually horrible
shots in fact the task force never
really felt like they were in danger
despite being fired on by several dozen
scp-4498
instances instead they hid themselves
and waited for backup but the personnel
were the only ones affected by scp-4498
site 53 was also host to a number of
sentient humanoid anomalies who are now
harboring the consciousness of jack
bright in fact in an incredible stroke
of bad luck site 53 happened to be
containing one of the most famous murder
monsters the foundation has ever faced
that's right scp-096
the shy guy the shy guy had been
relocated from its original containment
to site 53 and did now possess the mind
of dr bright security footage showed an
scp-4498 instance being lured to
scp-096's containment chamber
scp-096 now possessing the voice of
bright pretended to be a bright instance
locked inside the containment chamber
and asking the onlooking instance to
free it the instant suspected it was a
trap but the bride on the other side
assured him that he was doing important
um
science things and that this was
certainly absolutely not a trap
convinced by scp-096 is amazing acting
the
scp-4498 instance opened the chamber
door and let loose the scp-4498
scp-096 hybrid which threw the other
bright instance down the length of the
entire hallway as cp096 was elated to
run around the site and wreak havoc just
as the others were doing another bright
emerge from site 53's trash receptacles
covered in waste and sewage he spoke to
a group of rats encouraging them to join
him in the sewers below the raprites
praised their new leader and followed
him into the dumpster back up front the
brights led by pirate queen kiru had
constructed a wooden pirate ship over a
foundation issue m1 abrams tank bound
and tied to the mast was agent troy
lament meanwhile as the brights ran
rampant through site 53 dr mann and his
conference team were cooped up in a
storage closet hiding from the chaotic
mob actively looking for them needless
to say they weren't very happy after a
roll call check dr mann smelled
something foul and informed the
scientist turned golden retriever kane
pathos crow to remove his dog butt from
his face dr crow then informed man that
he was across the closet and that the
behind belonged to someone else in that
moment the real dr jack bright stinking
butt and all introduced himself causing
all of the closet crew to jump back in
shock bright tried to reason with man's
crew and begged them to let him hide but
the crew started debating whether or not
they should just throw bright to the
pirate crew for causing all this
ridiculous trouble in the first place
then dr crow in his infinite donkey
wisdom came up with a solution they
could find the cat statue repair it and
get dr bright to utilize as cp 963 on
the cat statue effectively freeing the
site 53 inhabitants from bright's
consciousness bright liked the idea well
until he realized that it might break
the amulet in the process and with that
the crew set off meanwhile the pirate
crew was posting flyers around the site
that read to the coward jack bright by
the high authority of her saltiest
majesty jack bright pirate queen raider
of the high seas mad butterfly of the
rolling waves we do command you to
appear before the pirate council to
negotiate the release or butt stabbing
and then execution of one troy lament
his crimes are numerous lollygagging
saying hurtful things criticizing queen
bright's very good hat this won't be
forgiven appear or be but stabbed dr
mann's crew had no choice they appeared
before the group of bright instances
that called themselves the high council
and began to negotiate for control of
site 53 dr mann gears bright and crow
spoke with pirate queen kiru and a few
other bright instances who all
introduced themselves in equally
ridiculous ways one was representing the
culinary jacks of the kitchens and break
rooms whose feasts were legendary and
apparently very tasty another was
representing the sneaky darkness jacks
of the parts of the site where the power
had gone out they are sneaky and very
mysterious as the representative pointed
out another was master jack lord of the
aquajax protector of the toilets and
sinks then you have the master of the
rats filth jack who asked the council to
behold as many armies of trash and
refuse and with that the almighty
council of jack brights had established
themselves the two groups began
negotiations to rescue agent troy lament
who as kiru pointed out earlier was
about to be subjected to a fierce butt
stabbing as agent lament was brought up
into the court pirate queen bright laid
out her turns scp-963-1
the amulet that contained bright's
consciousness bright was confused and
asked why to which kira replied that it
was because they weren't sure just how
long the
scp-4498 brights were going to last they
didn't want to suddenly die off and with
the amulet they could guarantee their
status as bodies of dr bright forever
bright refused and tried to appeal to
reason stating that since they were all
him he knew that deep down they were all
sensible people known for their good
instincts and controlled temperaments
this statement earned bright some raised
eyebrows from man's crew who knew of the
doctor's ridiculous exploits all too
well kiru once again asked for the
amulet
bride agreed but only if they gave them
the cat statue the council of brights
reluctantly agreed and the exchange was
made the statue was tossed to man's crew
who in response pushed dr bright into
the crowd of
scp-4498 instances who promptly
restrained the doctor while gears and
the crew attempted to fix the cat's
statue dr kiru pirate queen bright had
other plans for the capture dr bright
brandishing a comically large knife she
told bright that he was about to lose
something very important to his dignity
and manhood bride panicked and started
to plead with kiru just in time gears
tossed the cat statue to bright who
turned the tail back clockwise the
scp-4498 instances jumped back fell
forward again and rubbed their heads and
for a brief moment they were back to
normal dr kiru questioned her flashy
pirate outfit but because things can
never work out for jack bright it was
only dr kiru and clef who regained their
original senses the rest of the
scp-4498 instances were too far out of
range for the cat statue to work and to
make matters worse the statue
disintegrated seconds later now with a
restored clef and kiru and a rescued
agent lament dr bright and the rest of
man's team ran out of sight 53 being
chased by a horde of angry
scp-4498 instances once more following
their escape site 53 was recontained and
the current containment procedures were
established dr bright and the personnel
who escaped that day were subjected to a
series of interviews dr mann being the
renowned greatest surgeon in the
foundation gave a bombastic account of
the day's events where he downplayed the
importance and the help the members of
his conference team gave him during
their escape another member of the
conference team dr desi was particularly
upset at the apparent inefficiency of
the mobile task force squad sent to
reclaim site 53 wondering why one of the
hundreds of more competent task forces
couldn't have been sent instead to save
them all from the horror of having to
listen to jack bright talk to himself
for over 12 hours dr sophia light
informed dr bright after an awkward
reunion between the two that he was
going back on special probation as a
punishment for his actions a task
involving something with a wombat the
exact details of which are vague and
nebulous whatever the case dr bright was
certainly displeased by this agent
lament was still recovering from his
capture by the pirate brights and from
his shell-shocked state it seemed like
it was going to take him a while to get
over it dr kleff during his interview
admitted that he was late to the site
and was only pretending to be a bright
instance because he thought it'd be
entertaining after laughing to himself
about beating the captured troy's body
with a trout clef concluded his
interview with a single statement i love
the scp foundation now go watch scp
immortal dr bright explained and dr
bright for president scp-4444
bush versus gore for more on the
anomalously quirky dr jack bright